[Musique]
mais moi je cherche on est que toutes
les deux voilà je cherche donc vagin
müller il ya plus de problème vient plus
quoi c'est un gars se permet d'être en
retard et benjamin rocher saoudienne en
tout cas je vous dis bonjour même s'il
est pas là merci d'être avec nous à leur
valeur 25 sur france 2 alex n'est pas
rose comment tu sais que c'est une bonne
semaine qui commence bas c'est simple
quand tu ouvres les yeux et que la
première image que tu vois c'est
vladimir poutine avec un petit plaide
dans les genoux qui fait coucou à des
ogives nucléaires
là tu sais que c'est une bonne semaine
qui commence j'adore que les choses
soient classés j'en étais sûr je sais
pas pourquoi les dix premières secondes
les voeux je savais que c'était
wine si vous êtes comme votants voyante
je m'adresse à nos forces armées et aux
milices du dombass vous vous battez pour
votre patrie pour son avenir pour que
les leçons de la seconde guerre mondiale
ne soit pas oublié notre devoir est de
garder la mémoire de ceux qui ont écrasé
le nazisme et de faire tout pour que
l'horreur d'une guerre globale ne se
répète pas un discours d'une dizaine de
minutes durant lequel vladimir poutine
n'a pas annoncé la mobilisation générale
contrairement à ce que certains
observateurs attendaient
j'ai l'impression que vous êtes tous
pressés vous savez ce que fait même
quand on est médecin du travail quand on
est stressé haslam
aux cris 1 2 3 à
[Applaudissements]
l'hymne à la voix et de la danse au
coeur de l'hémicycle lors d'une
conférence de citoyens pour l'europe
l'occasion pour le chef de l'état de
pointer la différence entre le 9 mai
européen et le 9 mai russe
oui fond c'est à quel su à longwy non je
crois que vous faites erreur le
parlement européen vous sortez du studio
c'est juste un tout petit peu loin mais
dépêchez-vous parce que vos camarades
ont déjà du grand serre
les mains flotte tout autour de taper
l'une après l'autre du visage à la nuque
sur l'écouté le mou de teaser caresse la
nuque en passant
[Musique]
quelques minutes avant ce défilé
volodymyr zelensky prend les devants le
président ukrainien qualifiés de nazis
par moscou célèbre lui aussi la victoire
sur l'allemagne d'hitler ils défilent
seuls en chef de guerre sur l'avenue
principale de kiev et ligne combes nous
n'allons pas céder à quiconque la
moindre partie de notre histoire nous
sommes fiers de nos ancêtres qui
ensemble avec les autres nations de la
coalition anti claire battu le nazisme
et morena saison patron ce dec recel de
deux ans devenu un renifleur de mines
star dans le pays il a reçu la médaille
de courage pour service dévoué depuis le
début du conflit en ukraine ce chat
l'origine dressé pour la chasse aurait
détecté plus de 200 engins explosifs
dans le nord-est du pays cérémonie en
présence du premier ministre canadien
justin trudeau en visite surprise à kiev
coïncidence heureuse puisque la
technique de détection de ces bombes est
une technique canadienne et mélanie
fortier bonjour vous êtes une
conseillère régionale le rassemblement
national quel service public vous
souhaitez au rassemblement national
mélanie fortier quelle politique
la question n'est pourtant pas compliqué
quelle politique
n'a dessus c'est à dire qu'est ce quelle
est votre politique en matière de
service public qu'est ce que vous voulez
au rassemblement national quelle est
votre position je rebondis sur ce qui
vient d'être dit en face de vous
expédier son piège mais j'ai pas
tellement compris les questions
m pourquoi
à vous connaissez
ok le fait partie d'un club ou non ok
vous connaissez pourquoi tout ça
n'arrive qu'à moi et pourquoi est-il
tombé 1 à la renverse ou deux sur moi
si vous ne connaissez pas comment cette
chanson la bonne réponse et la deux et
bakel que marine le pen quel service
public elle veut aujourd'hui en france
j'étais désolé est ce qu'on pourra
couper cette partie du vin pas
compresser des sanctions alors on peut
pas couper parce que c'est c'est pas
possible
la politique est un métier